the conflict in Syria has claimed over a
hundred and seventy thousand lives
proportionally that would be the
equivalent of 2.4 million Americans
that's three times the population of San
Francisco since the conflict began 2.9
million Syrians have fled the country
and more than 6.5 million have become
internally displaced combined that would
be the equivalent of a hundred and
thirty three million Americans becoming
refugees that's more than the number of
people living in America's six most
populous states Lebanon has taken in the
most Syrians increasing its population
by twenty five percent that would be
like the United States taking in eighty
million more people
you